hello everyone we have a pretty amazing
game here that arises from a pretty
quiet classical variation of the
caro-kann the game was played in 2005
between two American international
masters level men and the Joseph Fang
they are international masters today I
don't really have an information on
their strength levels in 2005 but
chances are if their international
masters today that they weren't bad
players in 2005 and the game is
originally called well originally on
chess games.com the game is called the
defend as a Millman's opponent is called
Joseph Fang so it's Quetta got a catchy
title but I really enjoyed the game
because it reminds me of the old
American Beauty by Frank Marshall so
this is why I named the video
the modern American Beauty I hope you'll
enjoy it
Milman has the white pieces and he plays
efore so like we said c6 the caro-kann
d4 d5 Knight to c3 D captures on e4
Knight captures on e4 Bishop to f5 so
the classical variation Knight to g3
attacking the bishop bishop g6
h4 h6 making room for the bishop Knight
to f3 Knight to d7 and we have h5
Spassky variation
Bishop to Ace h7 Bishop d3 Bishop
captures Sun d3 Queen captures on d3 and
II 6 this is still all standard theory
Bishop to f4 and here we have
Bishop to b4 check and I don't really
understand this move so there probably
is some idea behind it but white simply
replies c3 and Bishop back to e7
so although but could have probably
played Bishop to e7 right from the start
this way it's like a white got the free
c3 move in there but maybe black prefers
the white want to be on c3 or something
I didn't really I didn't really analyze
the position too much here so if any of
you can figure out what's the idea
behind better
before check do share in the comments
here we have a queenside castle Knight G
to f6 King bee one we have castles
Knight to e5 now and c5 challenging the
center Queen to f3 and the screen to f3
is really an attacking move to to bring
the Queen closer to the Kings side I
don't really think that this Queen would
ever capture the b7 pawn and allow the B
file to be open for this rook Queen to
b6 we have Knight capture Sunday 7 night
capture Sun d7 and now d5 the idea of d5
isn't really well ok if you capture you
open up the D file for your rook but the
real idea is that if he captures on d5
you get this beautiful f5 Square
available for your knight and there is
one problem
if black allows white to capture D
captures on e6 the rook will get a
discovered attack on the night on d7 but
this could have been easily prevented
with rook a to d8 but for some reason
after this d5 move black decided to
capture a pawn he captures on d5 and of
course white immediately jumps into the
attack with 92f f5 Bishop to f6 now also
the bishop is guarding g7 and also maybe
attacking the Queen side after a
moon-like DeForest played rook captures
on d5 and we have Queen to e6 protecting
the night on d7 Bishop to h6 now
offering a bishop here is a very tricky
can this Bishop be captured well let's
check it out if G captures on h6 the
idea white head is a rock to d6 now
forcing the Queen to choose a square if
you play Queen to e5 it will lose the
knight on b7 and the King side is busted
open this is this is beautiful for white
the rock is coming into the game either
with rook to d1 or with a rock lift or
acacia tree rook to g3 White has a lot
of options here and if after up to d6
you decides to defended the night this
is even
if you play something like Queen to d8
you get rook captures on f6 and you
can't capture back the rook if you
capture the rook you get Queen to g3
would check King has to move you can
give up a night before that but the King
will eventually have to move Queen to g7
this is checkmate so after Bishop
captures on H six black decided first he
will play Knight to e5 and now he has
some more defence resources the knight
is attacking the Queen white replied
with Queen to f4 and what do you do here
Knight to c6 black offers a trade of
Queens we have Queen back to f3 and
black plays Knight back to d5 so mr.
Joseph Fang is offering a draw we have
Queen to e4 and the knight to c6 again
Queen to g4 now white declines the draw
if white played Queen back to f3 this
one would have been threefold repetition
it would have been a draw but Queen to
g4 was played so luckily for for all of
you great people on YouTube young 1109
wasn't interested in the draw and he
offers a whole rook so what's the idea
here can this rook be captured well
we'll definitely find out but now that
the queen is in G for a move like Knight
to e5 doesn't really work because of
rook captures on e5 and after Bishop
captures Bishop captures on g7
threatening checkmate
after this Bishop captures Bishop would
a discovered check from the Queen so I
have to remove like King to h7 pretty
much only move that blocks this Bishop
captures rook and f8 rook captures and
after rook to e1 Rock to g8 attacking
the Queen Queen to f3 rope to g5 and the
g4 this come this position is completely
winning for white black doesn't really
have a single useful move here so after
Queen to g4 black decided okay I'll
accept the rook Queen captures rook on
d5 white plays Bishop captures on g7
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries we have Queen
d 3 with check first king goes to a 1
and now Knight to e5 would attempt on
the Queen and here we have Knight to e7
check what's the idea the idea is after
Bishop captures Knight Bishop captures
knight on e5 with a discover check and
after you give up the bishop you give up
either the Queen with Queen to g6 then
pawn captures Queen but eventually King
has to come to h7 and this is Queen to
g7 again checkmate
so after Knight to e7 check black said
ok King to h7 and here we have a move
why I really enjoyed this game and the
way I considered the modern American
beauty queen to g6 with check and just
like Frank Marshall did it in his own
game the American Beauty okay here with
the black pieces
he played Queen to g3 here we have Queen
to g6 and black can capture the Queen in
three different ways
same as in the American Beauty with F
captures on g6 Knight captures in g6 and
Queen captures in g6 but whatever black
plays it doesn't really matter if Knight
captures on g6 then H captures on g6
would a double check from the pawn and
the rook the knight is protecting the
pawn so King has to capture the bishop
and this is rook to h7 checkmate and if
instead Queen captures it doesn't so
really matter it's all the same H
captures on g6 would check King has to
capture a bit of a rope to h7 check in
the game though after Queen to g6 check
F captures on g6 was played and here we
had H captures on g6 King captures on g7
and rook to h7 would a beautiful
checkmate
so yeah it's I mean okay it's almost
like the American Beauty sense in the
original American Beauty Frank Marshall
played the Queen g3 without check so
there is a bit more beauty to it but
nevertheless I mean you're you know not
offered his Queen to be captured in
three different ways very very enjoyable
so yeah that's the game for the other
game for today I do hope you enjoyed
I would like to thank Mendel Jacobs and
James Jeffery for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon